das ist so ich geh jetzt mal hier rein
drückt jetzt geht es geht nicht bloß
meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einer etwas anderen
minecraft fakten folge und zwar heute am
montag ich sag es schon sehr sehr oft
und zwar ist meinem posteingang extrem
voll mit allen möglichen minecraft facts
und ich hab mir gedacht da sind zwar
richtig richtig viele coole dabei
allerdings auch richtig viele die ich
einfach in massen zugesendet bekommen
dann vielleicht auch gar nicht
funktionieren die ich eventuell schon
mal vorgestellt habe oder fakten die
auch einfach total dumm sind und
deswegen habe ich mir jetzt heute mal 56
herausgesucht die mir immer und immer
wieder zugesendet werden die aber
einfach entweder nicht funktionieren
oder durch die schon vorgestellt hat ich
werde euch jetzt hier mal ein von wem er
zu gesendet wurde ich habe natürlich
alle namen immer zensiert aber einfach
nur damit ihr seht dass mir die sachen
wirklich zugesendet werden und zwar habe
ich jetzt hier einfach mal einen zombie
setzte den hierhin es wurde nicht
geschrieben hier ein kleiner weg für
dich wenn man einen zombie mit einem
schaden strang abpfiff bekommt es keinen
schaden erst mal das zombie ok hätte
nicht böse nehmen die leute die mir dazu
gesendet haben das soll jetzt nicht
irgendwie hetzerisch seien gegen euch
sondern einfach nur ihr könnt ihr nicht
wissen dass mir das extrem auf
zugesendet wird und dass das eventuell
sogar schon vorgestellt haben alles
mögliche aber ich wollte es jetzt
einfach mal in die eine folge reinpacken
weil sowas auch schon auf gewünscht
wurde hat dieser faktenlage noch mal
wieder gar keine fakten waren da wo dann
auch in die kommentare geschrieben
jahres stellen einfach die fakten vor
dir einfach richtig oft immer zugesendet
werden deswegen hab ich mir gedacht ich
mach das jetzt einfach mal und zwar ist
es so wenn man einen zombie mit einem
werk waren frank des schadens abwirft
passiert mit dem nichts weil es halt ein
untoter ist allerdings wenn ich ihn mit
einem trank der heilung abwehr bekommt
der schaden ganz eben weil halt ein
untoter ist untote sind schon tot das
heißt da drehen sich die effekte um und
wenn man zombies töten möchte muss man
die mit heiltränke abwerfen
womit schadens trinken passiert mit
denen einfach nichts ich weiß nicht ob
ich die sogar heilen kann damit kann ich
nicht aber die sache ist einfach das ist
ein fakt der mir echt extrem auf
zugesendet wird und einfach nur mal
freunde wenn ihr entdeckt hat dann
schaut verlinkt bitte erst noch diese
folgen beziehungsweise schaut euch diese
folgen weil das sind so sachen die sind
30 prozent aller sachen ihm zugesehen
werden sind was dieser erfolg jetzt den
zweiten effekt sehen wir jetzt mal
eingeblendet und zwar dass auch die
sache die mir glaube ich wirklich mit
abstand am meisten in den letzten paar
tagen ein paar wochen zu gesendet wurde
das sehe ich echt ich gehe immer vor den
folgen so zwei stunden vorher ich zwei
stunden
das durchschauen was hat nicht schon was
hatte ich noch nicht blabla und das ist
echt eine sache jedes dritte ist nahezu
hey du kannst im bett du kannst in wenn
du im portal steht ein inventar nicht
öffnen
das ist so ich geh jetzt mal hier rein
drückt jetzt geht es geht nicht
landschaft weg herunter gedimmt wie im
nette und bor das ist eine riesige
fläche folge zu hause jedenfalls ist
perfekter ganz einfach auch wenn ich
jetzt rein die und ich drücke
jetzt geht nicht ich kann nicht
erdrücken wenn ich im portal steht aber
nicht erzielen stehe ich kann ich hier
drücken erst wenn ich wieder hier
draußen bin kann ich wieder erdrücken
das ist immer zwei der ist ganz cool und
ich glaube den hab ich auch noch nicht
vorgestellt aber er wird mir einfach so
extrem ist oft zugesendet von allen
leuten ich glaube jeder dem infekt schon
mal zugesendet mit den effekt auch schon
mal geschickt die dritte sache ist hallo
lieber kräftig aber infekt für dich und
zwar wenn man einen gezähmten hund hat
und sich selbst damit einem teil
abschieds greift der hund ein an das ist
eine sache die wurde mir schon sowas
vorlauf zugesendet ich glaube dieses
sommers wird oft kann ich jetzt nahezu
bei jedem facts sagen weil davon gerade
die folge handelt aber das ist eine
sache wo ich sagen muss das geht bei mir
nicht also es ist wirklich so beim
effekt zugesendet werden wo ich denke
das ist interessant das könnte man
vielleicht mit in die folge nehmen dann
teste ich das natürlich auch selbst in
minecraft aus als ich nehme mir einen
hund gebe ihm ein paar knochen treppchen
gezähmten und und wenn ich hierhin laufe
dann kommt mir der hund
selbstverständlich dahergelaufenen du
besser kommen jetzt ist er hier
und wenn jetzt rein theoretisch mich
selbst mit dem bogen mit dem pfeil
abschießen hallo fall weil weil weil
weil ich treffe weil ich gehe dafür auch
erst mal kurz in den zu wort und zwar
schied ganz am anfang nach oben und ich
habe mich selbst abgeschossen und der
hund der macht nix lese ich mir doch
noch mal den kommentar durch ich habe
ein fake für dich und zwar wenn man
einen gezielten hund hat und sich selbst
mit dem pfeil abschießen reift der hund
einen an zugesendet vorgestern also in
der 1.8 version
ich hab einen gezähmten hund ich schieße
ein pfeil hoch treffe mich selber was
ist wenn ich den hund abschießen
dann greift ihr mich auch nicht an
diesmal mich nochmal ab also das ist
echt ne sache ich denke mir mal so wenn
mir ein fact zugesendet wird den ich
sonst noch nie gelesen habe und jetzt
ganz interessant denke ich mir schon
meistens erst mal der wird
wahrscheinlich eh nicht klappen weil
wenn er so geile sonntag ab damals ins
nie und das ist eine sache die wut mit
von lockert 20 30 leuten in den letzten
monaten schon züge in den letzten monat
jetzt schon zugesendet und es ist
einfach eine sache die funktioniert ich
also bei mir geht es einfach nicht weiß
was ich falsch mache oder ob es in der
1.8 gefixed aber das wurde noch gestern
zugesendet oder er spielt auf eine
gecrackte version und hat da noch die
1.2 beta oder irgendwie sowas und da
geht das noch nicht aber bei mir ist es
einfach so ich schießen fall nach oben
werde abgeschossen und jetzt kommt
angelaufen kommt angelaufen
also das geht bei mir ein wenig aber es
wurde mir so oft schon zugesendet so
freundlich befinde mich gerade auf dem
weg im netz
das ging relativ schnell ich bin direkt
schon da und ich habe hier ein bett am
start und das ist ein effekt der mir ich
die sache gar nicht mehr gewohnt mir
auch schon bis zum motto wieder zurück
bis zum jupiter wieder zurück zu
gewinnen konnte ich habe einen effekt
für dich wenn du im netz auf stellten an
schlafen willst du explodiert ist genau
das gleiche ist auch immense das kann
ich auch schon mal sagen und ich glaube
sogar dass ich das schon mal vorgestellt
habe würden dabei allerdings nicht so
ganz sicher vor allem wenn man jetzt
mittlerweile schon fast 70 facts folgen
am start wo immer fünf acts vorgestellt
werden oder drei fekter hat man schon
über 200 hektar am start und da verliert
man schon ein bisschen manchmal die
kontrolle und weiß nicht mehr genau was
habe ich schon vorgestellten was noch
nicht aber das ist eine sache die kennt
meine ich jeder weiß jeder schon mal
probiert hat wir haben es in mein kinn
in cap des 2 abs nicht in cap 2 in der
map ich müsste damit komme habe ich
selbst mit bekriegen müssen dass ich
versucht habe im bett zu schlafen und es
ging nicht und ich bin explodiert auch
voll dumm ich habe es gut aussehen
einfach angezündet aber mit dem anzünden
funktioniert auch also entweder ich
zumindest an oder ich versuche mich da
rein zu legen ist explodiert einfach und
jetzt habe ich ihn aber frei gesprengt
das ist eine sache wenn ich noch nicht
vorgestellt habe dann kann ich mir sogar
vorstellen dass es eigentlich ganz cool
a fake wäre aber ich meine ich hab schon
vorgestellt und es wurde mir auch so was
von oft zugesendet dass ein bett im
netter explodiert wenn man versucht sich
da rein zu legen und das gleiche ist
auch im end der fall also man kann
wirklich nur schlafen wenn man auch
wirklich in der normalen welt ist weil
im end und im neckar gibt es ja keinen
tag und nacht das sind ja alles hier
abgeriegelte bezirke und alles möglich
also was soll passieren wenn man denn
dann sind sie auf einmal dann sieht es
genauso aus also nichts verändert sich
in der im terra und ja das ist nummer
vier der mir auch so was von auf
zugesendet wird der fünfte effekt wurde
mir zugesendet von anonym ich hab's mal
wieder zensiert und zwar schreibt er
hallo luca luka ich habe heute mit
meinem freund einen coolen effekt heraus
gefunden nämlich wenn du auf einem
schwein wright ist und eine 5 modus der
schweizer unten betrachtest kannst du
sehen dass das schwein sitzen hat diese
schweine ist irgendwo auf mich
fokussiert das will mich dadurch
angreifen jedenfalls habe ich mir erst
mal so gedacht okay das ist eine sache
das ist na ja also das ist halt ein
schwein und schweiz sitzen und das muss
ich nicht wirklich vorstellen aber das
habe mir insgesamt ich habe in meinem
posteingang gesucht schwein von unten
das haben mir echt tatsächlich schon 15
leute zugesendet ich weiß 15 ist nicht
viel dafür dass nicht noch über 700
ungelesen effect zum posteingang aber
einfach wie kann man denn auch so was
kommen ich meine wenn ich jetzt hier mal
von unten aus und schwein gucke da seht
ihr okay das schwein absitzen wie wie
kommt man auf so was was ist das für ein
fact ich gebe dem jetzt einfach mal ein
sattel und ich glaube wenn ich doppel f5
drücken so nach unten gucken da seht ihr
noch mal ein schwein hat sitzen wieso
wird mir sowas zugesandt alter was muss
bedeutet natürlich ist es ein fake dass
ein schwein sitzen aber da kann man noch
sagen guck mal das schwein das hat hier
oben drauf davon
lidl
leberfleck leberflecken weiß ich nicht
ich habe ich gedacht okay das ist ein
fakt der ist zwar gut da hab ich mir
durchgelesen schreibt zurück ok cool
effect nehme ich aber nicht dran und so
ohne aber der wurde mir echt schon auf
zugesendet ich verstehe es nicht was
findet ihr so toll daran dass ein
schwein sitzen hat in minecraft was ist
daran überhaupt ein fake ich finde das
schwein sollte jetzt erstmal kleinen
höllentrip unternehmen hallo schwein ich
finde du solltest einen höllentrip
unternehmen
na ja meine lieben freunde jedenfalls
war es das jetzt mit der heutigen folge
zweiter der richtige facts folge sondern
eine folge wo ich euch mal zeigen was
mir am meisten immer zugesendet wird
wenn ihr auch irgendwas habt was wo ihr
euch denkt okay kommen das ist totaler
schwachsinn nicht so etwas als fix
bezeichnet schreibt man die kommentare
wenn ihr richtige fekter per mail an
kontrakte gmail.com es euch gefallen hat
das war ein einmaliges video mehr oder
weniger oder es kommt vielleicht noch
mal wenn es euch gefällt dann würde ich
mich selber ein bewirbt der tugend
freuen wie den uns morgen bei den
richtigen facts und tschüss